[Music]
hi what's your name my name is christina
hey christina i wrote my question down
because i'm nervous
um my question is and then i'll give
some context
how do you let go of the expectations
of someone who's no longer in your life
[Music]
last year kind of similar to josh's
story lost my mom
and my serious relationship ended
which was absolutely devastating
but what i realized is that i'm still
clinging to the expectations that my
mother had on me
i always felt sort of fortunate that she
didn't put pressure on me to get married
or have kids she never said
i really want grandchildren like what's
you know what's up with that but i
realize now that she's gone she did have
career expectations of me to always make
money always achieve more always do huge
things
and now i am doing big things i i am
earning more i am
self-sufficient and independent and
those are all
incredible things but i realize that
i'm trying to prove myself to somebody
and that person isn't here anymore
wow
i'm sorry for your loss
and i applaud the the bravery of this
question because
you have a couple options here you can
meet her expectations right
and make yourself miserable it sounds
like because if her expectations align
with what you want to do
then you wouldn't even question it they
wouldn't be her expectations of you
they'd simply be your expectations
of you
i'm sure if you've listened to the
minimalist podcast you've probably heard
me say that your happiness is moderated
by your expectations
the unfortunate thing about that is
our happiness is usually moderated by
other people's expectations that are
thrust upon us
so the how to let go
is not about doing something i wish
there were three things i could tell you
to do and then they would simply drop
it's simultaneously simpler than that
and also much more difficult
something that is simple isn't
necessarily easy in practice how do you
let go of an expectation
you stop clinging to it
that's the only way to let go of
something when we got here we flew in we
landed about four o'clock today thank
god everything worked out i don't know
how it did and i'm really grateful but
when we landed
we went straight to the hotel
and i dropped my bag off now imagine if
i were to ask the person at the front
desk how do i
set this down
he'd probably look at me say well you
picked it up
you're the only one who can set it down
you see i can't rip those expectations
out of your hands
but
understanding what is the
desire behind those expectations from
your mom
what does she really want from you it's
not that she wanted you to have some
sort of high power career necessarily
she didn't necessarily want the
specifics that she thought she wanted
for you she wanted you to be
happy and healthy and supported and she
thought in her mind though that is the
best path
to get you there
but you can take a different path and if
you still end up
where she wanted you to end up
well then that's pretty easy to
reconcile
i want to ask you mention the
relationship too
um so i have two part question for you
is there something specific that mom
wanted you to do that you're not doing
and that that's something you're
wrestling with
what did you mean when you said
expectations specifically
i mean she wanted me to have a life that
she didn't have
she really wanted me to have a career
and to be to not need a partner really
um
and so
you have the nice career we just heard
that
so
what is it do you feel like you've
disappointed mom
no i feel like she's not here for me to
tell her
whenever i have my successes which i'm
i'm having a lot now okay okay look mom
like look like look at me look what i'm
doing okay
okay and i'm gonna comment on that in a
second but i wanted to dig into that
there's something deeper here and then
anything along with this relationship
anything when you mention relationship
that that wasn't a part of the question
because you mentioned it
is there some expectations there you're
hanging on to
yeah there are that i would you know
that i wasn't supportive enough or that
i wasn't you know there enough i mean i
i cling to some of those expectations
that my former partner might have had
yeah of me okay
you know are relevant if we're not
together yeah
you just answered your own question do
you want to be with that person
no are they the right person for you
then who gives a crap
it's your life or their life
it's my life now let me tell you
something if you don't know it's funny
to acknowledge that everybody kind of
giggles and we all understand that but
if you don't actually start living that
way watch what's going to happen you're
going to begin to resent a person who
you don't even want to live with
you got to let it go
now on the mom thing i think it's a
little different
i i don't think that you've disappointed
mom you've made that very clear
you have to let go of the sadness and
you have to own that it is sad
it's real and it's okay to be sad
for a season
that you're crushing it
and the one person in the world
that you want to be able to call
or go see and go mom
i crushed a huge deal today
and you just want mom to go i'm so proud
of you baby
hey listen that's just being a human and
there's gonna be moments like that for
you for a long time
and it's okay that you're crying and
it's okay that you're sad
but
you can't do anything about that you
can't bring mom back
so hold on to the memory of what she
wanted for you which joshua really laid
out beautifully and know that she sees
you know that she's proud of you
and that's all you can hold on to you
hear me but you're doing great can we
give her some love she's crushing it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
you're doing great
you know any of these
expectations that we hold on to
especially when it comes from other
people like there's nothing wrong with
that like the question is we have to ask
is it serving the life we want to live
and it sounds like you know in your case
like some of those expectations are
serving you they're helping you do
bigger and better things and awesome
things and
maybe some of them weren't i think it's
it's awesome you've been able to kind of
decide for yourself which ones to hold
on to and which one to which ones to let
go of
it's amazing
hey i'll tell something uh personal here
so
one little quirky thing about me that my
friends make fun of me for is i listen
to christmas music every day
okay
365 days a year i'm not kidding
the people closest to me can verify that
it's true he makes us play it on the
podcast whenever he goes
and we love you for it t.k
so i'll tell you why when i was little i
had this uncle his name was uncle cleet
he used to own this furniture store in
the south china south side of chicago
called custom corner and it was on a
busy intersection and every year
he would clear it out and replace it
with christmas trees and ornaments and
and different kinds of holiday
decorations and he still had like this
big workshop in the back that they use
for like a lot of woodworking and stuff
and when you went to his store in the
winter time with all the different
workers and so on it seemed like you
were in the north pole i mean when
you've got a childlike imagination and
on top of that my uncle looked like a
chubby jollier version of my own dad my
father was very serious he's a pastor
not cracking too many jokes this uncle
would just be a total clown laughing all
the time and he was like my santa claus
and
i lost him
when i was in college and he always
believed in me
and he would always tell me that i could
do anything and he just always had my
back and there was nothing that i wanted
to do more than make that uncle proud
and i lost him before i could accomplish
anything
and
i remember one day i was in my apartment
and i was just thinking about him
and i thought about all those good times
at the north pole custom corner and i
thought about what he represents in my
life
and
it's like the middle of the year
i put on some christmas music
and i have no evidence that that man
could hear me and i said this one's for
you uncle cleet
and from that day on
i have played at least one christmas
song
every single day for no other reason
than to keep the energy that is him
alive in my life to remember the impact
that he had on me
and to do something in this world that's
different that's weird that's quirky
that's possibly inspiring that might
make someone laugh
as a way to keep him alive for another
generation and i say that because even
though we lose people
there's nothing wrong
with doing things that honor the impact
that they had on our lives and that's a
way that the energy of who they are can
continue to live through us and so i
think there's something okay to have a
moment that you set aside and you say i
did it mom
and you might not be able to hear me but
i did it mom and i'm gonna set aside
this moment in honor of you and i'm
gonna tell your story and keep you alive
in that way someone is going to know
your name and the impact that you had on
me because of what i achieve on this
earth because i'm never going to shut up
about you i'm keeping you alive i think
it's okay to do that
wow
christina we love you thank you so much
[Music]
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free